that was kind of the cool thing about
game stonks
is it was the right and the left nobody
was talking about politics
and it was a nice moment everybody's
like let's just screw over these hedge
funds
yeah i could i could totally see that
and i could see the reflection of occupy
wall street in that because
people were like together like they
really want to stick it together like if
i had done this exactly way better but
it's hard to keep together have you been
following that story like does it look
like that's going to continue
um well game stock has gamestop
stock has gone way up again
i think it was at like 113 again yes at
120 right now yeah
so i had held on to mine my diamond hand
yeah and i was like way down
and then i noticed it was going back up
the other day and i was like yes
all right yeah so you're talking about
it being down yeah 120.
that's great yeah so they're still
fighting i mean
what i mean aren't so for those who
don't promote the story it's like the
hedge funds were shorting gamestop
everybody bought in to basically strip
a ton of money from these hedge funds
who would be forced to buy
ridiculous amounts but are they still
like it's been like a month now
i mean i haven't really been following
it still but i i do have game stop
stocks so
i've been following it a little bit um
the guy who originally had bought into
the gamestop
stocks which i can't say my life
depended on it i just call it game
stonks because it's easier now
that's awesome but uh the guy who had
originally bought in i guess he bought
more
like a week ago yeah he doubled his
vision yeah the
deep fn value or the kitty guy or
whatever rory and kitty yeah and so
um other people i guess started buying
it and it went back up
it went up to like 150 at one point and
then i think
yeah i think yeah the peak well hold on
this is well today to date was 1
30. wow yeah wow dang if we're going to
seize control it's going to be with
through the economy not through the
pilot
yeah i've been buying all kinds of stock
now i had no i had never bought stock
never paid attention to the stock market
and then i was like i support this i am
jumping in
i'm buying some game songs and so now
all of a sudden i own like a million
different kinds and they're all into it
it's
it's great what do you use to get your
stock um
well i was using robinhood but then they
kept limiting and so
right now i'm using a few different apps
but i admittedly still have robinhood
because it's easy
but i don't recommend them i am not a
fan um
but yeah i've been i was like six flags
and disney
yeah the 52 week high is 483 for
gamestop wow
whoa someone bought in when it was at 18
in january and then they sold out when
it hit 400. yeah
millionaires overnight i think the
economy is going to collapse to be
completely honest
because right now you have
a meme economy we don't have a communist
command economy we don't have a
socialist economy
it's barely a mixed economy at this
point because of the meme ism
it's not laissez faire capitalism i
guess technically i guess you can call
it that
it's a meme economy where people make
money forget from getting attention on
twitter
they post something really dumb they
make something out of context they'll
insult somebody
try and get that meme to go viral and
then attach to it paypal me
but then you have dogecoin literally
just people throwing money into a meme
some people buy it they sell they made a
ton of money
and then with gamestop people are buying
this stock like crazy for what reason
it's a meme yeah it's a meme stock and
the crazy thing is like
people are becoming millionaires
overnight it was at like 40 bucks it
fell
down from you know 400 or whatever and
then someone was like you have to keep
buying in
and then the dude the dude one of the
shareholders of gamestop
posted an image of a ice cream cone from
mcdonald's
and then everyone went nuts speculating
that's what the ice cream cone meant
and then they all started buying up more
stock like crazy rallying the price back
up
it's people that's going off right yes
someone
someone became a millionaire
hypothetically i'm assuming it happened
i think there are a few
but i mean like imagine this you're
sitting there with like your eyes half
closed just glazed over and you're like
you know just putting a you know couple
hundred thousand dollars into game stop
and then
enter and then all of a sudden you hear
a ding and you look and there's an ice
cream cone on the screen you go oh
and then you'll get your account it's
like a million dollars like
all because a guy posted an ice cream
cone crazy the elon musk dogecoin meme
where he was holding up
was a kanye who was holding up someone
else gene simmons yeah something like
that
so i can't imagine an economy can
function that way like if you think
about how the economy actually works
with like
i we talked about this before i can't
remember who we had on the show we were
talking about this i mentioned
how does banking work like when when
when you spend money from one bank to
another
they don't physically give money to
anybody and then someone
commented it's just a ledger like
literally they just write down
he had 500 now he has zero and the other
guy says five zero and then 500
and that's just it literally they type
in a number on a computer press enter
and then the money's there
so you think about how how how absurd
that is
they can easily just type into a
keyboard you know type on a keyboard
press enter and then boom make trillions
of dollars
that's bad enough the federal reserve
and all that stuff add in all the money
they're printing over covid
add in the petro dollar and and just the
general market instability with conflict
let alone the covet crisis
and then add in the system is supposed
to be if you do work
that provides value to the system you
get value back to buy things and you
know do stuff
now people just get money from nonsense
yeah like
like i mentioned i think the craziest
thing is that people go on twitter
and they'll say like ian is super lame
enter
and then they'll wait for some retweets
and then add to it dude if you really
like me ragging on ian then
paypal me and i'll make fun of him more
and they're literally accounts dedicated
just making fun of people
so stupid imagine getting rich from that
i guess
entertainment's interesting with mass
media the ability to like make a video
and then it go viral and you can make a
million dollars and add revenues
relatively new i mean back in the day
600 years ago if you were a musician
you'd basically work for for your dinner
you know you'd travel around and
hopefully someone would pay you to stay
at the
they're in for the night and that was
your life but then mass media allowed
you to make
become rich as an entertainer
replicating that music
and then selling one record a million
times now all of a sudden instead of
performing one time you perform a
million times at once
and you're rich now that's what this
tweet this
tweet paypal stuff is too you know a
million people see that one tweet
i just figured it out i'm gonna start an
organization that issues
golden twitter birds gold
platinum and what what is it silver
silver
there's no silver records either
palladium no
you're not a gold record or a double
double a double platinum twitter yeah so
when your tweet goes extra viral
and then you you'll get a little
platinum bird and everyone can know
that's what you're famous for could you
imagine
the future is is depressing well in
addition all the things you're saying
about the people being able just to type
ledgers you know
the the petro dollar the inflation the
m110 supply there's
there's crypto which is now also
completely disrupting the global
monetary system
and i'm i mean i don't know are you deep
in crypto right now um
not really i have some bitcoin i have
some doge but i am not
super doge i'm starting to get a scary
feeling that
the people in in control if there's any
such thing are just going to crash the
whole thing and then become super rich
on the crypto that they've
i mean that's kind of how it's always
gone to an extent
but i wonder if you know when it comes
to crypto trading
you've got people who are making money
day trading cryptocurrencies because
they're
not stable becoming rich off of just
like
it's it's kind of busted yeah you know
and then they'll build an ai that does
it for them
yeah they do they already have that
they've been there been programs for a
long time where you can just
this is crazy there was a program i
remember what it was but you'd tell it
make me money and then it would be like
okay and
it just like would start trading crypto
it was it was something to do we talked
about this before where like some some
crypto was worth
one satoshi the lowest position of the
the lowest
decimal point for a bitcoin so it could
literally
only double in value it was worth one
it could be worth two that's it it
doesn't get any smaller than that
so you buy a thousand and then as soon
as it hits two
you sell them all and you doubled your
money and so there's programs that would
just find
the out of the you know hundreds of
garbage coins
and just buy all of the ones that are
sitting at one and then as soon as they
jumped it would sell boom
and then i'd wait for it to go back down
and then buy again it's just
somebody's losing money on that did you
what maybe i don't know i don't know
somebody's well somebody's buying in it
too and that's going yeah but then
maybe they saw three did you know you
know how much money these women make on
only fans
no how much there was one woman who
posted over a hundred thousand dollars
per month
geez yeah only fans
and so it was like there's a thread i
tweeted about it one woman said
something like
why would you use only fans like when
i'm there at the club the dude hands me
the money and then i've got it right
there i'm not gonna pay a fee to some
app
and then some woman posted after like
something like this monthly
income and y'all thinking i'm going back
to the club and it showed the breakdown
of all the revenue and it was like a
hundred and eight thousand dollars in
one month
and she paid like a twenty thousand
dollar premium to only fans
so now now twitter's announcing they're
gonna do super subscribers
oh how's that work you uh okay
you you it's not you all my offensive
tweets
okay so the liberal journalists come
after me
definitely i'm gonna i was i'm gonna put
most of my stuff on the paywall because
i don't want the trolls but then yeah
when i say things that you know piss
people off it's like well you gotta pay
to get pissed off
yeah it's gonna be really interesting
how the super super it might actually
fix twitter
it might because now these people what
they like to do
is they like to go to my or you know
cassandra's twitter feed or just any
other high profile person
screen grab it and then instead of quote
tweeting it screen grab it so they can
rag on you and generate hate
and then what they'll do is they'll take
like a screenshot of a tweet from
cassandra
then they'll tweet imagine being this
dumb what a far right loony
and then all of these leftists will be
like haha so damn so dumb and then the
original person will add don't forget to
paypal me or subscribe to my patreon and
try and monetize it there's there's two
possibilities
or not necessarily two possibilities but
there's two things that are going to
happen
people like that are not necessarily but
may
pay while that content because you'll
want to see what crazy cassandra said
you know but can you believe she said
this and then it says pay five dollars
to see this image
and it's cassandra's sweet yeah isn't
that crazy yep
so maybe though if cassandra puts the
tweets behind a paywall they're not
going to get it because they're not
going to pay for it
so if the troll won't pay the five bucks
for the post
they don't got to post it to share it's
a real troll toll
a troll i love it i'm into it yeah
if you want to get into this boy's soul
you got to pay the troll toll
do you guys know that reference no what
is that
it's from it's always sunny they were
doing the uh
the play oh yeah charlie charlie wrote
and the demon
danny devito was supposed to say boy's
soul but he kept saying boy's all
boy's hole you want to get into this
boy's hole you got to pay the troll
tonight he's like no
what boy's soul that's what i said i
gotta watch a show
that's a really old episode amazing
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time